hey there guardians this is alessandro
and we've got some more destiny 2
gameplay to share
exploring nessus we travel through a
vivid and lush landscape populated with
lost sectors and crimson forests hiding
many dangers
and opportunities for loot in this video
we take part in an adventure mission
that tasks us with helping our ai friend
fail safe with a number of bizarre and
strange objectives pitting us against
the time hopping vex
be sure to check out our other video
exploring the edz and comment below
about which looks more interesting to
you
thanks for watching captain
i have identified multiple data rich
caches to plunder
i have created an unauthorized login for
the friendly ghost
the vex will believe he is one of them
ideally
they will share their secrets that's
actually very helpful of you
let's see what we can learn
the platforms are charged is this a
deterrent or an experiment
i can never tell
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
they'll say this login is perfect i'm
pulling all kinds of data on cabal fleet
movements
zavala will love this happy to oblige
friendly ghost
marking additional caches
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i think they're on to us they believe
you are one of them
what did you ask nothing i asked them
what they're doing on this planet
did i offend them
[Music]
[Music]
these data cores the vex are dropping
they can take answers to my questions
perhaps they are attempting to interface
with the friendly ghost
and you captain are in their way
i'm so sorry i'll fix this
[Music]
i can't get them to stop they want to
tell me about the virgo prohibition
and how its algorithms are wrongly
deployed for the mars environment
how is that even relevant they say you
lack a holistic perspective
according to the network they are
sending you help
i don't want their help
ah
now i know why asher's ghost never talks
about her encounter with the vex
they keep telling me to come home
friendly ghost bad news the collective
is dispatching a vex mind
to help you terminate the captain
anyway this data is too valuable to pass
up
one more access point at the top tell
them to stop
so sorry i have no way to do that
but the vac seem to like you very much
that mind said one last thing as it died
it's afraid
afraid of your light the one thing in
this galaxy it can't
simulate probably old news to ikora
but i'll ping the vanguard your query
has terminated ghost
the vax collective hopes it has answered
all of your questions
a user within the network named osiris
sends his regards
oh i cora definitely needs to know about
that
[Music]